here now with reaction president Trump's
attorney former mayor of New York City
the guy that was responsible from
ringing the murder rate down from about
2,500 a year to way under 500 and I
remember almost every day you were
called the racist you saved thousands of
lives every year you were mayor here we
have cops treated this way mr. mayor no
cop is gonna want to save a life if this
is allowed to continue well this is very
very dangerous Sean and it's the result
of years and years by this totally
incompetent mayor of anti police
rhetoric going way back to when he was
first in office and the guy came from
Baltimore and assassinated offices blue
and Ramos assassinated them in a car
after he had made some very very
scurrilous comments about the NYPD the
NYPD is the greatest law enforcement
agency in the world Sean it is not a
all-white Police Department it's 50%
nothing it's white black Asian the
police office that you see being
assaulted with that water is an Asian
police officer rookie [ __ ] it oh it's
just out of the Academy and he chose to
do what do I know what I would do I turn
around and fight back I had I had at
least you know you know I run a security
business I work with a lot of police
officers FBI agents I I must have had 30
phone calls and 30 people that came up
to me police officers and FBI agents and
federal agents who said they understood
what this kid was going through if
you're on the job five six years you'd
have taken that that person you're the
rest of them this kid is on probation he
knows the mayor will turn on him I don't
care what the Blasio is saying now he's
turned on the cops over and over again
so now he's gonna be assaulted as a
police officer that's what we that's
what we're now telling and wears and
wears a Schumer AOC our Democratic
representatives in Congress where are
they standing up for the police no place
they're hiding
hell I'm standing up for the police
Bernie Kerik is standing up for the told
line Pat Lynch is standing up to the
police say you want do
where are they no cop is gonna want to
save their life if this continues this
goes back to Obama it goes back to
Hillary Clinton not allowing for
allowing uniformed police officers at
the Democratic convention their
disgraceful And the gentleman that was
on right before me is absolutely right
this leads to very serious crime the
Deputy Police Commissioner or officer
today held a press conference there were
random shootings going on in New York
now people being killed at being shot by
random bullets I inherited that and I
stopped it and Bloomberg kept it that
way and this I can't even say what I
would call him this mayor is a disgrace
and I don't care if he's saying it
shouldn't happen it shouldn't happen
because you can't happen you encouraged
it my friend
well I mr. mayor all right let me just
ask you a quick question about tomorrow
I want the real Russian story told by
Republicans in these committees your
thoughts on whether real Russian story
is that Muller was a complete
incompetent and he had a completely
disgraceful set of prosecutors including
Weissman who has been proven to have
basically gotten pretty close to
suborning perjury at least three times
including trying to get a Ukrainian
oligarch to give false testimony and
he's been he's been basically exposed by
the guys lawyers in John Solomon's
column yesterday that's what's got to
come out what's got to come out is this
was a plot it was a counterintelligence
plot that was conceived in Washington
and played out by Ukraine
UK Australia Italy they all cooperated
to frame President Trump this frame
attempted coup it was an attempt to stop
him and then to take him out of office
it's what we call a frame-up in law
enforcement and it's graceful and Muller
either knew about it or he's so damn
incompetent he didn't know about it
which maybe maybe it's even worse mr.
mayor
we'll be watching and it should be
exposed and on the job and if it isn't
I'll expose it the next day I got plenty
of facts so do i all right you can come
on my shovels do it together
the hour